tu es un homme maintenant va voir le
monde qui montre lui qui tu es j'ai le
bonheur d'avoir un jeune garçon mon
service m kelly mois là sont membres tu
là il est temps que tu te fasses à mon
[Rires]
but est d'apprendre des choses
actuellement l'homme
rien n'est jamais gratuit dans ce monde
mon fils soit un homme accompli ton
destin
[Applaudissements]
tu n'es pas l'homme que tu prétends être
tué un petit garçon qui cherchent un
capitaine qui nous disent quoi faire
tu es un on est des rebelles des
guerriers vous portez tous des robes
il ya rien qui fait plus peur aux hommes
que l'afrique
[Musique]
pour vous les combatifs d'une armée vol
oui messieurs vous êtes allé prendre dès
maintenant
je me reporte à maintenant
alsa pas maintenant
[Musique]
dis à ta mère que je lui fais mes
amitiés
leur fougue un homme peut pas changer le
passé ni changer le cours de son destin
tu es un homme maintenant tu es mon
petit a fait de moi le meurtrier le plus
froid qui ait jamais existé mais
d'autres connaissant la vérité dirais
que je suis un héros
ces puissances la chair
les italiens capitulait et les allemands
battaient en retraite se dirigeant
lentement vers l'ouest nous faisait
violemment payer chaque centimètre de
terrain en temps et ensemble
[Musique]
il y avait des patrouilles les snipers
des mines terrestres
continuer quand même ont été prudemment
un pied devant l'autre tout en tenant
nos fusils on faisait notre possible
pour rester vigilant malgré notre
détresse mêlée à la confusion et
l'épuisement ont continué à avancer seul
dans les décombres de la guerre et ont
continué à être puni pour ça oui
j'évoquais de beaucoup c'est beaucoup
d'allemands marsanne vrij et prenez h
joyner et iceman avec vous n'a aucune
idée de la taille de leurs forces
vous n'avez qu'a vous confondre avec les
arbres ou des portes aux couleurs c'est
l'un des nôtres
des tentures tenir eh bien on va
terminer cette mission cette mission
suicide c'est un peloton d'exécution
mais il va pas chez toi rhin
[Musique]
j'ai pris ma décision je vais rapporter
tout ce qui s'est passé ne sont plus du
tout les jours
[Musique]
ap
l'équipe
every man et le management
il ya deux ans
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au niveau cadet et ses vecteurs ribéry
n'ont pas
écoute je crois pas être prêt à bosser
en solo tu doit prêter serment
je promets de faire tout ce qui est en
mon pouvoir pour protéger cette ville
j'ai promet
[Musique]
or
keiko afoc la céramique
messieurs vous et vous remercions tous
les deux va falloir te cacher ne fait
confiance à personne et ne retire plus
ce masque
ça mettra
ils ont besoin de toi ça va avec
laundering ils en apprennent due forme
fink horreur pareille
j'avoue que je suis déçu hongre rigueur
mais tu veux pas à chaque fois que j'ai
l'impression d'être vraiment spider man
je fais tout foirer mares notre famille
n'abandonne pas chaque fois que tu dis
spider man c'est pour parler de l'autre
c'est toi spider man
tu peux y arriver
à ta façon
ce matin
qu'est ce qu'elle est
après la
charest
mats un match en retard
saint marin
[Musique]
plus tard
mais combative contre les esprits c'est
passé noblesse fatigue ou soit à dire
sous la dent
c'est pas
[Musique]
personne
spira
[Applaudissements]
costa
perdu
[Musique]
yeah
un de deux heures
[Musique]
yeah
un temps de 2 heures
[Musique]
m
expert line est allé aujourd'hui
avec
hors ue peine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
au cas où
le bas
mes chers
d'autre part
m
[Musique]